يوصلوا رجل الاعمال وملك تويتر الى ماسك
فضح الممارسات السريه داخل الشركه
والاحداث التي حدثت قبل حذف وتعليق حساب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب على تويتر
وكشف الجزء الرابع من التسريبات التي
نشرها ماسك ان الرئيس التنفيذي السابق
لشركه تويتر كان في اجازه عندما تم تعليق
حساب الرئيس ترامب وجاء في التسريبات ان
الرئيس الرئيس الشركه طبعا بعثا برساله
الى الموظفين عقب تعليق حساب ترامب اكد
داخل لها ان الشركه بحاجه الى ان تظل
متسقه في السياساتها بما في ذلك حق
المستخدمين في العوده الى تويتر بعد
التعليق المؤقت وكان من المفترض ان نشر
تويتر هو ان يرتكب صاحب الحساب خمسه اخطاء
وهي المهله مع مهله تصحيحيه حتى يتم
حسابه بشكل كامل وهو ما لم يحدث طبعا مع
ترامب حيث كان لا يزال الفرصه لتجنب الحظر
وفي الثامن من يناير من العام 2021 ثم
اعلان تعليق حساب ترامب وذكرت مدونه على
تويتر ان الشركه رجعت تغريدات الرئيس
السابق الاخيره وسياق المحيط بها على وجه
التحديد فيما يتعلق بالاشخاص الذين
اقتحموا مبنى الكابتل بالعنف في السادس من
يناير للعام 2021 واتخذ رئيس ستيوتر
الجديد الى مصر قرارا باعاده حساب ترامب
على تويتر بعد الاستطلاع في الثامن عشر من
نوفمبر